hey guys welcome back to brand-new good
Robecca I'm for night and today this
video is gonna be a guide on gladiator
personally one of my favorite characters
in for honor now obviously this
character has been out for quite some
time but I wanted to revisit him and
make a guide again with all the new
changes that came into season 5 and for
clarification I am a rep 43 but at the
time that I'm recording this obviously
represent a pristine Oh alot about this
character enough to talk about this and
make a guide and give my opinion on that
but I don't know everything about this
character so if I happen to miss
something leave them in the comments
below so that everyone could be up to
date on all the gladiator info needed to
complete the guide there will be
timestamps on screen and in the
description if you want to check out
some of the guides and the different
types of versions first we'll be doing
the beginner side which is strictly just
the move set and what is going to be
going you know with the Musa as well as
going over parry punishes and out of
stamina punishes very basic stuff and
then moving into it some advanced and
expert level combos and moves and then
finishing it off of my general tips and
recommended feats at the end of the
video to keep in mind so to start we
have the beginner move set and basically
as a small bit of info on the left side
in the hero specific tab it says that
gladiator has a reflex guard because
he's an assassin and has a larger
stamina meter faster regeneration than
most heroes in the game and reduced
cooldown time but gladiator also has a
lot of chain moves a quadruple light
double heavy light heavy double light
heavy
triple light-heavy and then quad
light-heavy gladiator also has a sprint
attack which if it hits does some damage
and comes from the top guard stance but
if miss can be followed into an
unblockable uppercut called bamboozle
which only does stamina damage and it
has the ability to ledge the opponent if
there happened to be by a Ledge or by
spikes or anything like that
gladiator also has a dash attack such as
the dash forward light inside dash
lights which can come from any direction
left or right watch out for these Muzo
because they are not only easily
detectable and can result in a parry
against you but if blocked can result in
a free guard break for the opponent so
use this move very sparingly
cutter can also do a sucker punch which
with his buckler hood simply by pressing
dodged in any direction or that be
sideways or forwards and hitting guard
break this doesn't do too much damage
unless you have the haymaker feet on but
it does a lot of stamina damage which is
the whole reason you want to use this
ability you can also follow this up into
a combo called cheap shot which is the
same as the sucker punch but with a
heavy attack at the end this heavy isn't
too hard to block but it is difficult
because all the buckler punches stun you
removing your guard stand switcher for a
bit and making you not able to see where
the hit is coming from next up is
gladiators infamous toe stab this is
simply performed by moving backwards and
pressing guard break this move while not
doing lots of damage is very quick
unblockable move that can be used at the
end of combos and mostly that is where
you will be using these from but it also
can be very deadly when a critical
health alternatively if the opponent is
out of stamina and you land the toe step
they will actually fall over to the
ground allowing me to get a free heavy
and it which then could follow up into a
lot more moves next up is a skewer and
while used in chain attacks only simply
moving backwards and pressing heavy
throws an unblockable skewer that can
lead into more options this can be used
whether in the first hit of the attack
last to the attack or in between and can
be heavy or light giving you a multitude
of options to on when to use this there
are three stages I like to call them
with the skewer that you can execute
that being no bleed half bleed and all
bleed which is what I'm going to refer
to them as no bleed is when as soon as
the skewer lands you immediately back
off by either dodging out of it or
throwing them away using the guard break
button full bleed is when once the
skewer lends you just sit there and in
full
max amount of bleed damage as possible
sadly though once you have hit this
stage you must fully commit and cannot
dodge out of this or throw the opponent
afterwards but then there's the middle
ground of half bleed is what I like to
call it somewhere between both of these
there is a small window of opportunity
where you can do a little bit of bleed
damage not as much as the full bleed but
just enough of a decent amount of bleed
damage and also throw them into a wall
or anywhere around you getting the best
of both worlds in my opinion and one of
the best of the three combos we will go
into a little bit more later in the
advanced in the expert section but this
was a quick overview and I will be using
those three terms that being no bleed
full bleed and half believed throughout
the remainder of this video as a way to
just help with the guide one of
gladiators next moves is his deflect and
this is simply performed by dashing in
any direction of the attack right before
it hits this will land a skewer and trap
the opponent you can then follow up with
what we mentioned in the skewer basic
info that being full bleed half bleeder
no bleed which we talked about a bit ago
this won't work on opponents with hyper
armor though like warlord Berserker can
say shibuki etc you could still land
this gear but if they have the hyper
armor on it will just bounce off of them
and then do no damage or bleed so
definitely choose wisely when you use
this move
gladiator also has a counter jab in a
counter jab heavy which is basically a
buckler punch by pressing guard break
immediately after completing a parry you
can optionally follow up with a heavy
attack if you want to this is definitely
one of the worst moves in his kit and
honestly isn't worth using at all so I
would personally just stay clear of this
move entirely and then lastly as one of
gladiators infamous moves his own attack
simply pressing the light and heavy
button you can perform his own attack
which is a 360 swing of his buckler
followed by the Trident if you hit the
opponent with the buckler the Trident
follow-up is guaranteed what if you miss
it you can feint it by simply pressing
the faint button and it will cancel the
trying to swing for parry punishes the
heavy parry will either give you a zone
attack or a dash forward light both do
the same amount of damage of 20 except
the zone attack also does stamina damage
but with the haymaker fie can also do an
extra 5 leading into 25 I usually like
to stick with that in terms of the zone
attack before the heavy parry
but if you're low on stamina you can
obviously do the - forward light to
conserve some of that stamina and then
for a light parry it's simply a heavy in
any direction since all the waiters
heavies do the same damage I believe
it's 30 damage so any direction works
it's entirely up to you furs out of
stamina punishes these are going to be a
little bit confusing but that's why I
have the video in the background to show
you but if they're out of stamina and
you've guard break and throw them to the
left
- forward light heavy faint into toe
stab and into heavy this will give you
sixty damage if pulled off correctly but
if it's off of a parry it's heavy heavy
faint into toe stab followed by a second
heavy which will lead into seventy
damage which is also a lot of damage
now the beginner version of this is done
let's move into some actual combos in
the advanced and expert move sets for
the advanced move set now we move into
combos the first bread-and-butter combo
I like to use a lot which has lots of
success is the light heavy feint into
another light from a different guard
stance like showing on screen I do a
light follow up with a heavy feint and
then into a light from a different
direction this combo mix-up has decent
success and is a good way to start a
match although this is on console which
what I plan on so this may not be as
efficient on PC if you don't want to use
a heavy attack simply swap that for a
skewer and do the same technique and of
course to end the match your combo just
hit it with the toe stab to go even more
you can even use a heavy feint but
instead of a light do a zone attack it
still works the same way you can always
of course end it with the toe step
another combo uses the skewer this time
land the skewer and throw the opponent
into the wall for the guaranteed heavy
if the opponent's back is to the Walton
you can smack them for stun damage and
then follow up with a guaranteed heavy
right after after both of these you can
then follow up with whatever you want
that being a toast a blood attack heavy
feint etc next combo involves the
buckler Sucker Punch after successfully
hitting a sucker punch you can then
follow up with the toe step or heavy
thing it's a light since their guard
stance is stunned and it will most
likely connect I like to use the heavy
feint into light a lot but the toe step
is handy for when their stamina is low
well enough so that the sucker punch
will knock them out of stamina and then
the toe step will make them fall on the
floor and they will have no time to
react on top of that you don't even have
to do and move it all and follow up with
a guard break while this move isn't
always recommended if landing can do
some serious damage cysts are out of
stamina and you could follow up with the
out of stamina punished that being the -
forward light into heavy feint followed
by toe step and then a heavy and then
for the last move in the advanced moves
that it's simply going to be a light
heavy feint in his own attack you can go
even more with this mobile we'll discuss
that a little bit later and the expert
move set or for this part you're just
basically like I said before do a light
and then into
Hevy faint into his own attack this
trains lots of your stamina but one
that's some decent damage on top of it
for the expert moveset we're gonna be
following up with what we talked about
in the last move in the advance move set
the light heavy feint into zone attack
but then feint the zone into a GB heavy
light or toe step if they're out of
stamina for even more damage to the
opponent of course if you happen to do
the toe step and they're out of stamina
just follow up with the heavy since
that's the most that you can get that's
guaranteed or if you want you can even
do a heavy feint into light to keep the
combo going from the bread-and-butter
combo we talked about in the advance
move set next is a variation of the
skewer once landed do the half lead we
talked about so that you could still get
some bleed damage but also have the
ability to dodge and do a dodge forward
top light you can either end this with a
toe stab or a heavy feint into another
life to keep the combo moving you can
also do heavy feint but instead of light
follow up with the zone attack same
thing works as well this will most
likely drain all of your stamina but
regardless it's still a move that you
may want to use and it's mostly used
when the opponent is on critical health
to get that last bit of help out of
their health bar next up is my favorite
move which is a zone attack which can
either be from the heavy parry or just
the move in general but if the opponent
is out of stamina faint it into a toast
ad to catch them off guard watching your
opponent stamina is very key because
some players know once they're out of
stamina the gladiator will try anything
that they possibly can to toe stab them
and get the guaranteed heavy so they'll
probably keep a watchful eye out and
dodge anything that comes towards them
that's why you wait until their stamina
is still low enough but not out of
stamina so of them when the buckler hits
them from the zone attack and knocks
them out of stamina faint the zone
attack into a toe stab to get your
guaranteed heavy and then the last move
is a sucker punch into double heavy
feint which you could fall off with a
light or guard break I don't use this
move too often as you choose up lots of
stamina but it does have a very high
success rate is because most players
will expect the first heavy faint but
never the second if the opponent happens
to swing for the fences and it try to go
after the first heavy then just cancel
the combo and parry the move and
continue going from there from there you
can obviously do the top light and then
start going into heavy faints and then
the light attacks from different
directions like the bread and butter
combo we talked about for the events
move set or alternatively you could use
the zone attack and then feint it into a
toe step if they're out of stamina let
the zone attack grip for the guaranteed
damage or feint it into a guard break
heavy faint light attack etc it's
completely up to you
and then lastly to finish off the video
we have general tips and feets for tips
you use your - moves very sparingly
because doing too much can result in a
free guard break for the opponent or a
light payer which is not good news next
is to watch out for your stamina
even though gladiator has faster
recovery of stamina than most heroes in
the game
he wastes a lot on his own and since
that's one of his best moves in this kit
it's something to definitely keep in
mind and lastly is to always incorporate
some type of combo or mix-up in your
move since he has one of the best mix
ups in the game and can really confuse
the opponent during the match for feats
for the first beat I recommend bounty
hunter simply because you get stamina
and health on every kill the others
aren't as useful in a very situational
second fee I only recommend haymaker
because your buckler now does five
damage on top of the stamina damage and
the stun capability same with before the
other choices to me are very situational
compared to haymaker for the third and
fourth feet it's also up to preference
for the third feet if you want to have a
long-range single target attack go in
Neptune's wrath long range AoE attack is
boom go mortis or the bull odorous if
you want to trap the enemy and start a
combo fourth feet like I said is also up
to preference if you want d buffs then
go with fear itself a wee damage go with
the catapult and then if you want to
buff yourself go with the roar of the
crowd and yeah that's going to be the
end of the guide that was the for honor
gladiator full guide that being beginner
advanced and expert moves it as always
if I happen to miss something that you
find it very enjoyable or some type of
move or strategy that you use for
gladiator that I missed leave it in the
comments below for everyone to be caught
up on that I really appreciate it
oh yeah with that like the V if you do
enjoy subscribe for new I cover the
informational side of foreigner as well
doing some gladiator gameplay but the
informational side of foreigner includes
balance changes hero updates patch notes
all that other stuff and I like to do
guides on some of the heroes that are
coming in the future as well as doing a
lot of gladiator gameplay since as I
stayed at the beginning he's one of my
favorite characters in the game my two
most recent videos will be on screen if
you guys want to check that out when
that guy's a burger yesterday thanks for
watching the video hopefully you learn
some new and peace out